did you know TV teens are rarely played
by actual teenagers Jenna Ortega's
gloomy Wednesday Addams is supposed to
be 16 but Jenna was born September 27
2002. she celebrated her 19th birthday
shortly after the first season began
filming in the Autumn of 2021 birthday
yes happy never if you found yourself
fooled by her short stature that's
because she's barely five foot one
meanwhile the actor who plays
Wednesday's Crush from the nearby town
of Jericho was considerably older Hunter
Duhan placed Tyler Galpin he's supposed
to be a teen around the same age as
Wednesday but IRL the actor turned 28
during filming he may be older but the
actor turned bestie is not Emma Myers
plays the overly enthusiastic team
werewolf Enid Sinclair Enid is 16 the
same age as Wednesday but Emma was 19
during filming she's just a few months
older than Jenna she's also a similar
height which helps her look young and
speaking of Joy Sunday plays the queen
siren of Nevermore Academy Bianca
Barclay Wednesday's rival is also 16 but
joy is older than her co-stars she
turned 27 the month after filming
wrapped in Spring 2022. Bianca's
on-again off-again artsy boyfriend
Xavier Thorpe is played by Percy Hines
at the start of filming Percy was just
19. one month into shooting he turned
20. he fits right in with Jenna and Emma
here's one that might surprise you Musa
Mustafa plays Eugene odinger nevermore's
resident bee lover his characters
roughly 16 too but Musa is just 13. we
don't know his exact birthday but it's
safe to say he was 12 when he shot the
first season back to some normalcy
Georgie farmer is Ajax a 16 year old
Gorgon Georgie was 19 during filming
just like Emma and Jenna his age is
probably not super surprising but the
actor's British accent might be you
think you got it figured out but then
it'll just switch on its head so
suddenly another British actor Naomi J
Ogawa plays Yoko Tanaka Naomi turned 22
right before filming began and since
then she celebrated her 23rd birthday
but enough about the students the
legendary Christina Ricci plays Miss
Thornhill Wednesday's dorm mom and
botany teacher if the actress looked
familiar it might be because you've seen
her as Wednesday in the 90s Adams Family
movies Wednesday Adams Christina played
the role between the ages of 10 and 12.
Miss Thornhill on the other hand is
supposed to be in her early 40s well so
is Christina she was 41 during filming
Game of Thrones star Gwendolyn Christie
plays principal Weems the character is
morticia's old Nevermore roommate and
both characters are supposed to be
around 49 and 50. IRL she was only 42
when Wednesday began filming in
September 2021 Oscar winner Catherine
Zeta Jones is the latest actress to
tackle the role of Morticia and she's
close to her character's age Morticia is
supposed to be around 50 and Catherine
turned 52 at the beginning of shooting
her birthday is just two days after
Jenna's meanwhile Luis Guzman played the
husband of Morticia Gomez Adams like
principal Weems and his wife he's
supposed to be 49 or 50 but he has the
biggest age gap between character and
actor Luis was 65 during filming he's a
full 13 years older than his on-screen
wife
[Music]